welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we've been watching The
Watchmen to break down everything that
you need to know about the new show on
HBO episode sevens just dropped and the
ending of it has a lot to unpack from it
most notably that one of the main
characters in the season has been dr.
Manhattan this entire time there's
actually been a lot of clues and hints
dropped during the season so far and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down all of the indicators that
tease what was really going on there's
gonna be heavy heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch
episode 7 of Watchmen yet and don't want
to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of all the hints
and clues for the dr. Manhattan twist
okay so episode 7 of Watchmen finishes
with Angela rushing home to her husband
after hearing from lady true that the
7th cavalry are planning to abduct dr.
Manhattan and kill him
replacing him with Senator Joe Keene
upon arriving home Angela tells Cal that
she loves him who we learned throughout
the episode has complete amnesia after a
car accident
Angela plays whack-a-mole with his
forehead and pulls out the symbol for
hydrogen which is also the symbol that
the doc uses on his forehead for
branding shutouts the guys in the
marketing department we begin to see a
blue glow in Angela's eyes and it turns
out that her husband Cal has been dr.
Manhattan this entire time now there's
actually been a lot of indicators for
this lace throughout the series and even
so far back is episode one there were
some strong highlights that cowl was the
doc it's definitely a case of what if
God was one of us and it seems like the
doc has been lying low for some time in
the body of Cal now firstly you don't
cast a guy who's been in black mirror us
and Aquaman as a househusband and that
should have initially been enough to
give the game away though there are some
slightly more obvious hints that come
early on the first time we see dr.
Manhattan is in episode 1 in which he's
building a castle on Mars this is later
revealed to be the same castle
Ozymandias inhabits on the Jupiter moon
of Europa however we also see Angela
Kal's adoptive son building one that is
very similar to it Cal could have
possibly helped to build this and guide
his son as he would have all of the
structural information on how to do this
this castle was something that I first
didn't really understand but in
retrospect it makes sense why the two
are building similar structures also in
that episode we'll flat out tells Angela
that dr. Manhattan exists on earth and
that he is hiding out as a person as we
learn throughout the series will is
telling the truth all of the time and
thus everything he says here is to be
believed
Angela later brings this up with Cal who
says that's impossible and she may have
been testing the character to see if he
actually remembers it or if whatever was
placed in its head was truly working
personally I believe that the hydrogen
symbol at Angela pulls out is made of
tachyons which as we know from the
watchmen graphic novel are capable of
limiting dr. manhattan's ability to view
every moment of his life simultaneously
this will explain why cow has tricked
them these year which as lady true says
is almost unheard of it also explains
why Cal has no backstory and why before
the white knight they didn't have any
children now I'm not a biologist and
every couple can struggle with bearing
children but it is possible Angela and
Cal are unable to have them however doc
knew that they eventually would and all
they had to do was wait we do see
someone sitting on Angela's porch who
says he's there to see his grandchildren
however Angela threatens him and this
highlights that all of Angela's children
are adopted she writes him a check and
sends him away which to me shows that
she adopted the children in
non-conventional ways as Cal has no past
and thus he would be unable to provide
proper documentation to the body that
would deal with handing over the kids
colors also play a huge role in watchmen
with a lot of characters having their
own schemes and so on on the channel we
actually did an interview with watchman
colorist John Higgins last year which is
definitely worth watching if you want to
know more but in that we kind of
discussed how certain characters have
certain color schemes and these actually
carry over from the graphic novel into
the show for example veidt's colors are
purple and yellow and this is pretty
much as brand whenever we see the
character again shout outs the marketing
department mirroring this Cal often
wears different shades of
blue which is of course dr. Manhattan's
color we see it in his t-shirts jeans
and so on and we also see a big flash of
blue in Lori's dr. Manhattan dildo which
just so happens to be named Excalibur
slow it down and you probably get the
best Easter Egg in the show ever X Cal a
bar as in Cal a bar is her ex dr.
Manhattan and yeah great work guys I
absolutely love that like comment and
subscribe to the marketing department
those who've looked ahead to the episode
titles will have also noticed that
episode 8 is called God walks into a bar
which again God walks into a bar aka
next week is about Angela meeting John
for the first time in a bar anyway Lori
is aware of how they met and when
talking to Angela about Cal she's very
forward about enjoying the time that she
spent meeting him Lori talks about dr.
Manhattan and says yeah well he's no Cal
Cal your husband a song today we had a
nice chat you guys met in Vietnam right
who knows maybe he was flirting a bit
with his old flame and she saw the
similarities with him even though she
may not know who he is as she did still
spend a lot of time in that prayer booth
as we know from the graphic novel Lori
and Jon's relationship was strained
massively because of his detachment from
humanity and it is possible that she
also said he's no Cal because she
recognizes the things that were missing
in her relationship with in theirs
Angela had a very close call in her past
in which members of the seven cavalry
attacked her in her home during the
white night in which they wiped out the
majority of Tulsa's Police Department
during the lead-up to the moment that we
see the cavalry enter Cal is constantly
looking at the clock and then he
disappears and not long after
potentially to transform and save her
life the capital remember is about to
shoot Angela at point-blank range when
she blacks out and wakes up in the
hospital now how she survived this we
don't know well well we didn't know but
it's obvious now that Cal wiped out the
home invaders saving Angela from a huge
brush with death speaking of death when
discussing what happens when you die
with his daughter at the breakfast table
Cal says that before life you are
nothing then you live and then you
become nothing
again this is a kind of a WTF moment
especially for Angela who say hello and
it sounds eerily similar to something
that dr. Manhattan would say namely that
a live body and a dead body contain the
same number of particles structurally
there's no discernable difference
definitely sounds in line with the
character and again adds a lot more
evidence that they are one in the same
reddit user case Endor also compared dr.
Manhattan and Kyle's fingers
side-by-side and show that they were
indeed the same actor which yeah that's
nuts to me there's someone got that far
into Airport a great job you definitely
solved the mystery before all of us even
considered it now going forward it makes
sense that the doc would want to go into
hiding as he would no doubt be aware
ahead of time that the 7th cavalry
planned on kidnapping and killing him so
that Joe Keene could take his place the
best way to cover this up would be to
completely wipe his own memory and start
a new life in a small town where very
few would ever suspect that the
character would go doc made a grand
statement upon his exit in Watchmen and
the fact that he had been spotted on
Mars several times will also draw
attention away from where he truly is
before carrying this out I can see him
informing Angela of all the things that
would be coming ahead so she at least
had some prior knowledge of it Angela
did say that they knew this day would
come so it's safe to assume that he did
at least brief her in advance of exactly
what was going to happen
this would have prepared her for what
was coming down the line and it would
also allow the two to understand when it
was time to lose the facade in cases
such as the white knight in which he was
needed doc also told Angela that she
would die protecting him and it looks
like their time together may be coming
to an end with the latter potentially
dying during the seventh cavalry attack
I'm guessing that John will be weak
which is why he can't intervene and that
also explains how the cavalry may have
the opportunity to kill him as he will
be at his most vulnerable either way
this is a clear indication that
hindsight is 20/20 I love going back and
seeing these clues in the early episodes
that let us know that the two characters
were one and the same
obviously I'd loved hear your thoughts
on the reveal and if there's any other
hints and clues that I missed make sure
you leave them in the comment section
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to check out our full breakdown
of episode 7 which would be linked at
the end we go over all of the Easter
eggs and give our best fan theories on
the series so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more we
also do a podcast called watching The
Watchmen and which we break down the
original graphic novel issue by issue so
if you want to know the full backstory
of the book then make sure you check it
out after this that's where we
interviewed Watchmen colorist John
Higgins clear go and watch it you'll
enjoy it if you want to come chat to me
after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which should be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel or more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Watchmen in the comment
section below but when it's gonna be
chosen the 15th of December and the set
will be shipped out from the intro ever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]